Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
Joining us today for his third appearance
on the show is an extraordinary human
and absolutely exquisite storyteller.
Somebody who writes really beautifully
about the things that matter most.
What makes us who we are?
The decisions that shape our lives.
And he does it in a very idiosyncratic way
that will make you laugh.
Leave you pondering your own life a little bit more deeply
and perhaps feeling just a little bit less alone
in the world.
His name is Jedidiah Jenkins.
He's a friend.
He's my favorite follow on Instagram.
Both his books are New York Times bestsellers
and his latest, which we talk a lot about today
I think is his best work to date.
It's called "Like Streams to the Ocean."
It's so good.
I think you should just hit pause right now and pick it up.
I adore this man.
I love this conversation.
It's all coming up in a few, but first
we're brought to you today by
The Plantpower Meal Planner
because I think we all aspire to eat better,
but most of us struggle when it comes to
how to make it stick.
So we created a platform that takes all the hassle
and the guesswork out of optimal nutrition
by giving you affordable access
to thousands of customizable,
delicious, easy to prepare plant-based recipes
that are constantly being updated,
built in with automatic grocery delivery
of everything you need.
Plus access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
ready to answer all your questions seven days a week.
To learn more and sign up is at meals.richroll.com.
And right now we are offering a special deal,
$10 off an annual membership
when you've used the promo code RRHEALTH
for just a dollar 70 a week
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com.
All right, do me a solid hit that subscribe button.
And without further ado
it's time to go deep with Jedidiah Jenkins.
I mean, it's awesome to see you.
And I was realizing that the full extent
of our entire relationship is based on this.
I know, and yet we go so deep together.
I know, and then we always depart with grand,
you know designs on like hanging out all the time
and then that never happens.
And you accuse me of living in Dubai.
Well, that's true.
Yeah.
As an East-sider making the hike.
East-sider it's just the lifestyle over there.
I mean, when you live this far out,
is it more of an understood burden
that you're the one that goes or to your friends?
A hundred percent,
I mean that the consensus is you essentially
live in Santa Barbara and if you wanna see your friends,
like you're the one who's gonna have to make the effort
more than them because it's such a schlep.
Or you plan out a dinner party way in advance.
And like, hope there's not a pandemic.
Right. But yeah, exactly.
Like good luck with that right now.
So the sole extent of my social interaction
like everybody is either on Zoom or in the few rare
and beautiful instances that I can cajole people
like yourself to come here.
To have even distanced real human interaction
is a treasure.
So how's it been for you?
I'm a double extrovert as you know.
Enneagram seven.
Enneagram seven full on
like not built for a isolated pandemic.
But living in Los Angeles to the degree that I do
I feel very lucky that we live
in a place with you can be outside.
And there's so many places to hike and walk
and I've been able to go on neighborhood walks
with friends and things like that, go to the beach
and whatever it is even go camping way out in the desert.
And that's been a lifesaver just to have something
on the horizon for your camping trip in a month.
For an Enneagram seven, we're always looking to
we just need the next adventure in the calendar to like
be able to exist today, which is probably--
You still live with roommates?
Yeah.
You do.
So you have a bubble of like friends.
I've never lived alone.
I'm a, full-on grown adult man never lived alone.
And I'm curious, I think if I am uncoupled
when I enter my forties
I have decided that that's something I wanna do.
Try living alone.
Even though I, it just feels like a performative gesture
of experiment because I don't want to.
I love my roommates and I love coming home
to their watching some show I've never heard of
or they're making some new cocktail
that they saw on TikTok.
And I'm like, what's that?
And then there's something happening
which I enjoy the energy of that
as opposed to coming home and then I'm home.
And then I'm like, I wonder what my friends are doing.
I guess I should reach out.
And then if they're busy,
then I'm like, well I guess
no one wants to hang out with me.
I just can see myself going through a spiral.
There's a weird sort of cultural negative
pejorative, veneer over the idea
of an adult living by himself or herself.
And if you have roommates after a certain age
that's frowned upon
but we're genetically engineered to live
as a village in a community of people.
And my favorite,
some of my most favorite memories are being
in a dorm or living in a group house.
And why can't we do that for our whole lives?
Why is that?
Why would that be considered,
going awry as opposed to the preferred state of existence?
I think, and we've talked about this
ad nauseum on this podcast,
but I think--
I forget, I don't even remember what we talked about--
Well, but suggest the sense where,
growing up evangelical Christian
and then having my homosexuality, like uproot or like
cause the deconstruction of an entire worldview
that I was raised into
and taught this is how the world works.
And then this one factor of my identity sort of like
pulled the thread of the sweater
and started to unravel the sturdiness of that worldview
that has like given me this like comfort
in not doing what I'm supposed to do.
Right. Like being outside the paradigm.
Yeah. Like you should be married by this age.
You shouldn't live or should live with roommates.
You should do this.
Like I just have exercise.
I've exercised that identity muscle of being like,
well that's not what I wanna do,
so I'm not gonna do it.
So as an Enneagram seven,
I'm a four with a wing of five.
I'm still not sure what exactly that means.
But you seem like somebody who understands
the Enneagram pretty well.
Like how does a four slash five interact with a seven?
Well, we tend to like each other because
as far as I understand
when a seven, so my wing is a six
which is loyalty and following the rules
which would make sense because I'm fun,
but I also wanted to be such a good Christian boy
that I had my first kiss at 28.
It's like, I'm crazy
but at the same time
I didn't lose my virginity until I was 30.
So it's like there's aspects to my major number.
So a four being the individualist
doesn't wanna be put in a box,
like you find yourself to be profoundly unique.
And so any like categorization
of you in a generality is offensive.
And then a five is insatiably curious
about the way things work.
So you being a successful podcast or
where you dive into very complex nuanced issues with people
in an intimate conversation feels very four wing five.
Yeah. And I like the one-on-one.
I get nervous and anxious around,
group settings and things like that.
And you know, I think I'm fundamentally an optimistic
somewhat joyful, but maybe traumatized individual.
But I like my alone time
like I would have no problem being alone.
I just spent essentially a month in Hawaii by myself
and it was the greatest,
which is not an Enneagram seven trait at all.
Well, when I say, I like my alone time,
I mean three hours.
Like, Oh my God, I was alone.
I went on a walk.
I just thought about some things
and I'm recharged let's party.
It is interesting.
I would suspect most writers though are not sevens.
I think you're right.
And my writing practices
when I'm on a book is I can really only focus
for two to three hours a day, like on one thing.
So I write I'm freshest in the morning,
I wake up and I wrote this book.
I finished this book in February of 2020.
So that's right when I turned it in
and it was done, done, done.
And I was like free the world shut down.
But I mean, luckily that's not like I lost my job.
I was like, I was meant to be doing nothing that time.
So that's interesting.
But in my normal world behavior,
I wake up, I go to the coffee shop,
I have to find a coffee shop that serves food
a full menu because I'm gonna sit there for two meals.
I have breakfast
and then I sit there all the way through lunch.
But you have to be around other people
in your solitary moment?
The buzz of others
and also as a writer, I don't have like an office
and to separate work from home
is like somehow psychologically symbolically important to me
to like go to work and then come home.
And so A, leaving my house is important to me
and also the harm of others.
Cause I also don't have coworkers,
which I really miss
from my days at Invisible Children and in school
just having other people in common endeavor.
I have my editor and my publicist
and the people at the publisher,
but they're all in New York
and they're just an email relationship really.
And so I miss that.
So gonna a coffee shop
the barista knows what my order knows me.
It's very like it's as close as I can get.
And it's just a lovely lifestyle.
I love it.
It's pretty good.
Well, this new book is fantastic.
I loved it so much.
And all the praise that you're getting
I know it's just made the New York times bestseller list.
It's unbelievable.
And it's just there's something
so specific about your style.
I can't quite put my finger on it
but when I'm reading your writing,
I always know that it's you.
Do you have a sense of what that is?
Like, could you define that?
Or is that just it's just such a natural extrapolation
of who you are as a person that it's one in the same.
Well thank you for being so kind to me.
Yeah. I mean, I do love the
I have so many things I wanna say about it, but go ahead.
The only thing I know is that I write the way that I speak
and I don't labor over the crafting of a sentence.
I don't, I'm not very precious.
I labor over the crafting of my understanding of an idea.
And so I try to write something
out to the point where it makes sense to me.
And so, however my brain uses metaphor and whatever that is
once I've laid it out and I'm like, there it is.
That's what I was trying to think about.
And that makes me feel
like I'm at least getting some sort of touch on the idea.
Like, I can finally this gray fog in my mind
I can now touch it.
There's something physical there.
And so I've just been,
it's one of those things I've been told
that I have a writing voice.
I don't know it, but it's funny when my editor
or if I write something for a magazine
or for my editor, for the publisher
sometimes they'll reword something
or send me back some changes
and the slightest change in the sentence,
I'll be like, I would never say that.
You know it right away,
you're like, that is not
I don't know if you've ever been like driving with someone
in the passenger seat and you hand them your phone
and you go, Hey, can you text Sarah that it'll be,
I can't come right now,
but I'll come tomorrow, whatever.
And then they type it out.
And then I say, "Let me see what you wrote."
And it's like, I would never
I would use an exclamation point, not a period.
And my smiley faces do not have a nose, that's insane.
It's like, you can immediately see that
that's not how you type.
Yeah. So it's more that,
it's not that you can define what it is
other than what it's not.
You can immediately identify what it's not.
And I would say that it is true
that it's about the idea that you're trying to present
and you don't get overly caught up in the pros.
The pros is uniquely yours
but it's not about the trappings of language
because the way that you write is very,
in a good way like, plain-spoken,
it's not about big words or anything like that.
It's about conveying an emotion
or a feeling or an experience that is specifically yours.
And I think,
the two things when I think about this book are,
first of all, it's a masterclass in this precept of writing
which is you find the universal in the specific
and these are your experiences, your memories,
there are stories from your life
and they're so specific to your experience.
And yet within that, there's something
about the way that you convey these ideas
that makes them unbelievably like universal
and such that the audience can really
emotionally connect with them.
Like our life experiences are very different
but when I read your writing,
I feel less alone because you have such a you're so in touch
with your interior landscape and
there's more that we share with that
than what differentiates us.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. I mean, what you're describing is exactly
the reason why I wanted to be a writer
because I loved nothing more than the feeling
that writers gave me when I would read their books.
And I read mostly whether it was
straight dead men or black women,
or these people that I would read
who obviously have a different life experience
than me to some degree.
And I would just ache with being seen,
and even where their lives diverged from mine,
they had a way of pulling me into their experience
where it was as if I was them,
because that's one of the super
maybe the most important evolved characteristic
of the human mind is the concept of other self of empathy
of the idea that I can picture what it is like to be you.
And that is what creates community
and charity and morality
and everything is this idea of the concept of self.
And that's really like the humming truth
behind the concept of consciousness.
It's the, like, what would it be like to be you?
And if that, if you can answer that question
then the thing might be conscious.
Is that am I remembering that right?
Cause it's like,
I would never say what is it like to be a table?
You would be like, it's like nothing,
you're a table,
that doesn't mean anything.
But if I said, what's it like to be a dog?
You could kind of feel something there
you'd be like I can kind of feel,
I know what my dog is thinking a little bit
like squirrel food, lick me, I wanna lick you,
I got it you know.
And then as it goes up from there,
but I feel like the best writers can make me feel
what it is like to be them.
And so for me,
I learned it's if I just tell
a very specific story about my life
and how it made me feel
a reader they're like active empathizing with me
pulls them in and they feel very much like they know me
which is an interesting side effect of being a memoirist.
I mean, you know this you've written
extensively about your life.
It's inviting someone into your story is such a unique
is such a unique job because
when people walk up to you and they say,
I feel like I know you, they kind of do.
They kind of do, yeah.
A hundred percent they do.
And there's a vulnerability with that.
But it also, it's nice.
I love it.
It's such a shortcut
to being able to connect with people.
You know what I mean?
You read my books and then you still
wanna talk to me then we probably we'd get along.
But the downside of that is that
if someone is to write a critical review of your books
they're criticizing you.
You know what I mean?
I forget if I told you this story before
forgive me if I did edit it out.
But Ann Patchett is a very famous, fantastic novelist
from she lives in Nashville and I've met her a few times.
We've had some great hangs.
She's just radiant.
And I asked her, would you ever consider blurbing my book?
This was for, "To Shake the Sleeping Self."
And she said, "No, I will not."
She goes, I do not blurb memoirs because she goes
if I don't like it, then
if I don't like a fictional story that you write
I can say why I can say this story didn't land for me.
I don't really connect with Somali pirates.
I don't really know.
But if she says your life story doesn't connect with me
or bores me, or that is such an indictment of my idea.
So she goes, I just learned I do not blurb memoirs.
And I was like, that's a good rule.
Yeah, that is.
Well, the other thing is that
and then I'll get to my second big observation of your book.
But the other thing is that there's this idea that
and you see this in movies and in screenplays that,
the protagonist or the character has to be somebody
that we can all relate to.
And my relationship with books
and why I love reading memoirs is at odds with that.
Like, I wanna inhabit the interior experience
of somebody who's lived a life, nothing like me.
And within that, you know
I can find something to grab onto or identify with
but I'm not interested in somebody's dumbing down
their story so that it can be widely appealable.
It is that it is that fidelity to being super specific
to your own experience that makes the book work or not.
Well, you're a type of person because you've spent
so much time examining your interior life
and your own influences and desires,
I think you're curious about expanding
that self knowledge through the human experience
mapped on to other life experiences.
A lot of people, they haven't,
they don't have the bandwidth to worry about
someone else's lessons.
They're still trying to figure out why am I sad?
Why am I unhappy?
And so the closer the story is to them,
that's like a step in the direction
towards expanding those neurons of human understanding.
For me, I'm like tired of thinking about myself.
I wanna know something.
I wanna know an experience so different than mine.
And I think about, do you ever watch a movie
that you feel like no one else saw
and it just, you didn't even know you liked it at the time
but it like haunts your mind for years?
There is a movie, I mentioned it in this book.
It's I forget which book I mentioned it in
but it's called "Away from Her."
And it is this movie about an old
this old couple and the wife gets dementia or Alzheimer's
I don't know the difference.
And she began and they're in love.
They are like love story married for 30 years.
She begins to forget him.
And it's his experience losing the love of his life
but she's right there.
And then she loses the ability to live at the house
cause he has to go to work or whatever
so that she has to go into a home.
And then he visits her.
And then over the course of the movie, he'll visit her
and she's scared of him because she doesn't know who he is.
And I mean, it's this heart wrenching story of loss
and like aging and all of these things I know nothing
about except that movie sits in my heart.
And just, it's weird because of the power of storytelling,
I feel like that could happen to me.
And there's like some,
I have some immune response to it.
Now it's almost like storytelling
is the vaccine of the mind.
It like primes your brain to be prepared
for scenarios that haven't happened to you.
Or you experienced that in a past life.
Do you believe in past lives?
Do I need to believe in that, I'm ready.
I'm not against believing in them.
Well, me neither.
I would say that.
I have friends who are V into them.
Very, very, very, and I'm not,
I mean energy cannot be created or destroyed.
So it's like.
But the I'm sure you've had those experiences
where even countered something.
And it has, I mean, what the story you just told
as an example of that,
like where it has an outsized impact on you given,
what you would anticipate it would.
Like I could have just seen that movie
and forgot about it.
And so why is that so resonant for you?
Well, maybe there's something there Jed.
I like that.
But on that subject of you talking about,
the reader asking themselves the question,
like why am I sad?
Your first book "To Shake the Sleeping Self" in many ways
and tell me if I'm mischaracterizing this
but it's like a coming of age story setting
on this bike trip where you ride your bike
from Oregon to Patagonia.
And I knew, before reading your book,
I know this next book.
It's kind of gonna be lifted
from his blog posts and his Instagram posts.
And you know, by the way
you're my favorite storyteller on Instagram.
I just, I love everything that you share there.
You and Josh Brolin are my two favorites.
He's amazing, right?
When is he gonna write a book?
It's incredible.
When he shares a story, I read everything.
He is wild on there.
He surprises me constantly.
I love it.
Its completely not what you think
it's gonna be every time.
And I'm like, where is this the profundity
of his thought process is unbelievable.
Mixed with the playfulness of it.
Yeah. And there's something,
what you share is different,
but there's a specific sensibility to it, I think.
And kind of having that understanding
going into your next book, I'm like,
I wonder is this just gonna be a hodgepodge
of like Instagram posts,
but what it really is and I'm interested in,
if anybody else has has had this observation,
this book is a Trojan horse
because it's really a disguised self-help book
shrouded in your personal stories and experiences.
And it's kind of amazing
because the other idea I thought I had thinking about
what's Jed's second book gonna be about it's
like how much life has this guy lived since his first book?
Like has he tapped out yet?
Is there more in the well,
and you know I was delighted to find out
there's a lot more in the well
and it's not a self-help book, but it really is.
And even though the architecture
and the way that you've laid it out,
categorically by going through,
ego and friendship and family and work
and all these different categories
it lays out this framework for a young person
or anybody who's asking themselves these questions
about who am I?
How do you know, how do I fit in?
Where do I belong?
What is it that I'm here to express?
Like you speak to all of these things and,
with a confidence and a kind of,
effervescence that is really connective.
Like I just loved it.
So, yeah, it's great, man.
Thank you. I mean, the funny thing is,
and the whole premise of my first book was,
I wanna be a memoirist
my like heroes re like whether it's Henry Miller
or Don or Donald Miller when I was younger
these people who were writing these books
from their own personal experience.
I was like this is my dream to be able to do this
like Joan Didion, Fran Lebowitz, these people.
And yet I was in my twenties when I had this realization
I was like, how embarrassing.
Why would anyone listen to me I just got here.
So then it was the idea
of the Benjamin Franklin quote
"either write something worth reading
"or do something worth writing."
So that was the like major impetus for going on a trip.
And then, so then when my publisher was like, okay,
let's do another book.
And I was like, well, I don't have a gimmick.
Like, why are people gonna read this?
But at the same time I felt very affirmed.
Well, okay, this is just an interesting journey of my life.
So I gathered a readership
of my live experience writing about my bike trip.
Like tens of thousands of people started to care
about what I was doing on my bike trip.
When I finished the trip,
I was completely prepared
for them all to leave because it's over.
So the reason you're paying attention is now over.
So leave, great.
And not only did they not leave
but the following like doubled and tripled.
And I didn't
sometimes I would write about what does it mean?
What is Michael Jackson's musical legacy mean?
I can't stop thinking about this.
I'm just gonna write about it
because I have a captive audience
like maybe they'll hate me maybe.
And things like that would be spread all over the internet.
And so what I slowly realized was, okay,
my imposter syndrome was telling me
that the only reason they're here
is the gimmick of an adventure.
But actually the reason people are subscribing
to the magazine of my Instagram and the things I write
is they're just interested
in the angle with which I see the world
like the framing of an idea.
Not that I know what's what the truth is.
It's not that I have answers.
That's just, I have reflections and responses to things.
And for some reason
because it helps me to like
finding words for things that are bothering me helps me.
And I just believe that if something helps you
it probably helps someone else.
And so tell people about it.
Yeah. And you're working it out in real time
not from a position of authority
but as somebody who's struggling,
just like everybody else
and doing it in a very authentic way that,
in genders that kind of
like kinship with the people that are following you.
And I think there was a timing aspect of it as well,
because if memory serves me initially on Instagram,
they would cap out like how many words
you could make your caption.
Like you couldn't write like a full blog post
and at some point they broadened that.
And you were one of the first people who kind of used it
as your personal blog.
Like it was more just a one-line caption.
And used to roast people for doing that.
When they first started it
and they wouldn't post as long thing.
I'm like, I'm not on Instagram to read
get this out of here.
I mean, and before the, like the algorithm
your friend would go to Paris and come back
and post 42 pictures of the same cathedral.
So you're scrolling down and you're like
I'm furious that I am now inside this person's camera roll.
And they're just like in Paris,
like get outta here
I'm here for a different experience.
But what I found was,
as I was on my trip the longer the thing I would write
the more response people were
like wanting to be on the trip with me.
And it was, I mean, I think
at least my life has very rarely been
a strong decision against the current.
It's always been like, is it called tacking
when you say all we're used exactly
it's like responding to the movement of the wind
and the current, and just kind of trying to make headway
towards a life that I wanna lead
but really responding to the environment.
And so, people seem to like it.
If I write more, I'll write more.
They like it if I write a lot more.
And then while they're still here
so I'll just keep thinking.
I would say just as a fan that
whether you're sharing,
you're doing an Instagram story of you and your mom Barb,
traveling through Europe or talking about,
whatever frivolous thing
like the Britney documentary or something like
I'm just as interested in that as you,
riding the Patagonia because it is your frame.
That's what I'm dialing.
That's what I'm tuning in for.
Well, and I think we,
the interesting, fascinating moment in time we're living in
is that every human being
if you have a smartphone
and internet access can create a window
into their life that is moderate
or is highly curated or just is what it is.
And that also is interesting.
Like I know that just me being myself
being an outdoors-y, gay,
[Indistinct] but also like culturally Christian,
Southern boy who spends most of his time in Los Angeles
like this combination of traits,
for whatever that cocktail mix me just existing in that way,
I get messages and emails all the time
of somebody that's like,
just watching you live makes me think I can live,
watching you laugh
like watching the way you talk to your friends
makes me realize my friends don't talk to me like that.
And I maybe I should try to like find people
who are more similar to me
or whatever it's it,
there's so many unintended consequences
to just living out loud.
And I mean, for me they've been enormously positive.
When I think of your work,
I think you mentioned Joan Didion, Fran Lebowitz.
Did you watch the Fran Lebowitz documentary?
Ofcourse. And I'm devastated that they took
did you see the original one called "Public Speaking"?
No, I went, but I did.
I did go on to like a YouTube deep dive
after watching the documentary
and just watched a ton of her stuff.
So I don't understand why this is happening,
but in 2010 Martin Scorsese made a documentary
just like "Pretend It's a City",
but it was two hours long.
And it was for HBO and it's called "Public Speaking".
And back then I saw that and became Franz
like the one person in the world
I saw her walking down the street in New York
five years ago and I about self immolated.
I was so overwhelmed by the side of her.
And of course I would never talk to her,
but and I went to see her speak when I was in Austin
I just left.
And then they took the documentary away
which I don't know why.
And then "Pretend It's a City".
Maybe it's because of that.
Cause they're very similar,
the structure is identical,
but that's a lot of the things she says
in "Public Speaking" have shaped so much
of the way that I see the world.
Like she really brings the heat in that one.
And I wish it would return.
So if I ever find it, I'm gonna send you the link.
It's cool. I loved it.
And I was delighted with just how in love
Martin Scorsese is with her.
Like she just can't stop laughing
throughout the whole thing.
And it's kind of flawed.
It's like how many times do we need to see her walking
into the club.
And it's a little bit weirdly repetitive with her meandering
through the mini New York city and all of that--
Asks for six episodes.
And he's like, well, I have four episodes
of content and he's like film more walking.
And he just teased her up to do her thing
and say the things that she says.
I mean, the difference if I was to draw a distinction
between how I perceive you and her, I mean she's
there's a relish in her being contrarian.
That isn't really kind of what you're about.
But she's so convicted in her opinions
and her like her hand, man mannerisms and just her
just everything about her is kind of an
it's just amazing that she exists
in the world and the world is better for it.
Well, it's one of the things around comedy as a structure
is so often flawed and a lot of comedians don't age well,
or their comedy doesn't age.
Well, because you realize they were punching down
not punching up.
And she has just been really good
about punching up her whole life.
Like when she makes fun of something,
it's either a structure or a person in power
and not the easy jokes of people
who can't defend themselves.
And so I think that's why she's making political statements
and punching in the direction
that you should punch if you're gonna swing.
I mean, the other influences on you clearly
Cheryl Strayed and Elizabeth Gilbert,
I know you, didn't you do like a panel with them.
Maybe we talked about that last time.
Well, I mean, I've, I spoke at a conference with
with Cheryl and she is just, there's just,
it's like I was just as impacted by her book,
"Tiny Beautiful Things" as I was with "Wild",
which is so interesting
because this is similar in that structure
of one is an adventure and well,
"Tiny Beautiful Things"
I don't know if you've ever read it?
I have read that one.
She has an advice blog
she used to call "Dear Sugar"
and people would write in.
Now it's a podcast.
Yeah, of course.
Fantastic. And, but she
for years they didn't know who she was,
but she they would write in and say,
I mean, I was abused, I had an abortion,
I have guilt, I have shame all these things.
And then she would just write her responses
and they became very popular.
And so she took those and put them in a book.
And that was an inspiration for this book
in a sense where it was small stories
but like they landed on me so hard.
And it was such a, it was an enjoyable reading experience
because you could just sit down with your coffee
and have a moment,
like a encapsulated moment that morning
that you had done something
like reading a New Yorker article or Atlantic.
It's like, yeah, I completed this moment
and I felt good about my day,
which I wanted with this book to
you were able to have like small meals.
Yeah. I liked how you, you talk about Liz Gilbert
as like this idol and how you fantasize or imagine her,
in this perfect life where
she's just sort of effortlessly,
gliding through her house and dropping,
amazing advice on people and without a care in the world.
And it's all coming very easy.
And of course she's a human being
but that is not that is not how you
imagine her to be when you're kind of trying
to channel that influence on your own work
and then turning like flipping the script
and understanding that perhaps there's people
that are looking at you in that same way
My friend Jackie Tohn just had wore this shirt
the other day that I immediately had to have.
And it just says,
"remember when you wanted what you currently have"
and it just landed on me, like, wow
what an amazing thing to write
on your mirror or think about every day
is remember when you wanted what you currently have
or I remember hearing this pastor say that
there's someone in a hospital bed right now begging
and praying God to just be doing
what you're doing right now.
The mundane thing you're doing right now
is their ultimate dream.
And just like framing things
like that are very powerful to me.
And yeah, I remember so clearly,
well I wanna write a book.
I wanna see it in a bookstore.
Wow! On a shelf I want.
And like, for it to say, New York Times bestseller
on it wasn't even a thing I don't even
because I still don't really understand
how that happens or what that is.
So it's not a, I almost have no visceral response to that.
It just was so beyond,
I was just like I wanna hold a thing that I wrote
because my I love a book in my backpack,
like and flipping through it and the reverence
with which I would like hold my first books and just
I would just flip the pages and like watch them fall.
And I'm just amazed that that's all my brain in there.
And it now my agent was saying this yesterday
he was like, books have this effervescence of
of permanence different than like
if you write an article on Medium, great.
But if you have a book that just feels
like it's been placed in this longevity,
it's sunk its roots into the earth
and we'll be here for awhile and that has weight.
And that is so true.
And so even though I can logically understand
that the difference between Elizabeth Gilbert
and me is I think she's a better writer
and a better speaker
but I know that she's just a normal person.
It probably a great hang, but there is really
I mean, anybody, I mean, literally anybody
no matter if you're a Barack Obama
they're just people that have been put
in these situations that are extraordinary.
And I find idolatry
and like idolizing people to be a very young trait.
And I think we're probably evolved to be that way.
You look up to a role model to a mentor--
It's important.
Because it gives direction--
You can latch onto an aspiration
and it's embodied in somebody that allows you to
visualize it and perhaps like map your own path forward.
Those people are super important.
Yeah. And that does, for me,
it has faded as I've gotten older,
just understanding more about the human experience
and also achieving dreams
and being like, I mean, let me be very clear.
I am a writer and I have the best life.
I love it.
I am so happy.
I'm obsessed.
I can't believe I get to do this as a career.
It is everything I dreamed.
I get to speak on stages.
I have strangers writing me letters.
I have strangers coming up to me and telling me
that they came out of the closet because my book
or they understand their daughter or son better
or they quit their job and booked a trip to Angola.
I don't know, like incredible stories.
What a privilege, what an honor, what a dream.
And yet I'm still me.
And sometimes I sprained my ankle
and I'm like why and whatever it is
it's you never stop being a human,
no matter what you achieve.
Yeah. But on the subject of the t-shirt and
remember when, you know, how does it go exactly?
Remember when you wanted what you currently have.
I've heard you speak about the idea
of pursuing your passion and this sense that you have
like when you were working with Invisible Children,
you were maybe it wasn't your dream, but that you loved it.
And you were making an impact
with the work that you were doing
and placing this idea of work and passion
and all this pressure.
I think that particularly young people feel like
if they don't know what their passion is
that they feel somehow like to have a broader lens on
on what that means and how you think about work.
I really think that the idolatry around passion
and feeling like your work completes you
is really strange and problematic.
I mean, I'm such a sucker for biology and anthropology
and like the concept
that we lived in tribes for a million years
and then we discovered cities 10,000 years ago
and agriculture it's like the way we live now is so weird
strange to what our body is.
And for a million years of our existence
you either caught an animal to eat it or grew
or you didn't even grow anything
maybe you foraged some mushrooms and some berries,
I don't know.
And then you had babies and you like hid from animals
and you'd like, try not to eat something that was poisonous.
And so it wasn't like hunting fulfilled your spiritual soul.
It was that these things were very cause and effect.
There was clarity in the cause and effect,
if you ran faster and longer than the gazelle,
you got to eat it and now you're full.
So the effort you put in had a reward
if you raise this child
then that child can not only love you and you love it
but then it can also help you hunt
and it can help you farm
and it can help you raise the other children.
There was such a clarity.
And I think as we stratify stratified
and expanded and built the concept
of an economy and industrialize the world and this and that
and that linear relationship between
cause and effect and reward was removed,
of course that creates a crisis in mental health.
It's a crisis of meaning,
the more comfort and luxury
and free time that we have,
the more we're allowed to kind of indulge with,
the interior life.
And there's something about that that is aspirational.
Like you wanna be engaged in that.
You wanna be asking the big questions
and wrestling with your place in the world
and what does it all mean and that's great,
but at the same time it creates,
it creates this sense of disengagement with the world,
or what's really important.
Like it's not in its proper context.
Like if you're not pursuing a career that,
you're waking up every morning,
doing jumping jacks because you're so excited
that somehow you're a failure
or you're not doing it correctly.
And we have social media and algorithms
and you know what we're fed on our devices every day
that just foment that sense of less than.
And you have a lot of like podcasters and books
and like here's how you go chase that dream and whatever.
I mean, even me and "To Shake the Sleeping Self,'
it's like quit your job and go bicycle to hello.
That's it.
I mean, at the same time
the wrinkle on all of that is, that's what I did.
I felt a calling in my heart that I wanted to be a writer.
And so I took a risk, quit my job and became one.
And I really am that fulfilled
happy person doing their dream job.
I am the thing that I'm critiquing right now.
And I'm saying that me by me doing it
it worked and I am the happiest person I've ever met.
So take everything I say with a grain of salt.
But I do believe that sort of, when you were saying
about my experience in all of my twenties
working at Invisible Children or going to law school
not knowing what I was supposed to be doing.
By the way as an aside, the whole thing that you did
on law school was so great.
Like here's what happens when you go to law school
and you kind of you know,
I went to law school too.
Like, here's how it unfolds.
I mean, that's exactly the way that it happens.
And I was on the precipice of,
becoming that person and got out of it.
I've seen so many people walk that path
and become that person to the extent that at one
point I thought I wanna put together like a keynote,
like a speech and just tour law schools,
and just get up there and go here's
what's really gonna happen when you graduate from here.
You can get them assembly line.
And it's this, like, it's an entrapment
that you've constantly told yourself.
You will not be in trapped by
and yet they just lead you down.
You just keep moving the goalposts
and making excuses for yourself.
And to sort of fill the gaps in your,
lack of fulfillment and what you're doing.
You gird your life with all
of these material possessions
and you become indebted to them
and your life becomes more and more complicated.
And you ratchet up "Keeping Up with the Joneses".
And then you're 50 years old
and you're a senior partner at a firm.
And you're like, well, I guess in the next life.
Right. And you don't know your kids or what they're into
because you work all the time and then they're mad at you.
And you're like,
"What! I look what I bought you."
And they're like, "We hate you."
And you're like, "What!"
But so all that to say, I didn't know.
I had this like passionate calling to be a writer
until I was close to 30.
I thought I was burned
by this idea because when I was a little kid
I saw "Jurassic Park" when I was 10 years old.
And I was like
this is the best movie that's ever been made.
And I am gonna dedicate my life to dinosaurs.
And then I realized I have to become Steven Spielberg.
I have to, I'm so obsessed.
That was my first like true idol.
And then I was obsessed
with all his movies and James Cameron
and George Lucas and that generation obsessed.
And I started telling people,
I'm going to become the next Steven Spielberg.
So buckle up.
And so all of middle school, high school
everyone knew this.
They were like, everyone was like,
Jed's gonna go off and make movies.
He's gonna move to Hollywood.
And I'm like, that's right, I am.
And to the degree where when I graduated high school
teachers asked for my autograph.
Because they were like, wow, here he goes, he got into USE.
But you know, props for the conviction.
And I think it speaks to how powerful it is when you
when you kind of declare this is who I am
and the world kind of coalesces around that idea.
And they're like, yeah, I guess he's gonna be there.
Yes. I mean, there's also the,
there's also the tall poppy syndrome
where people wanna cut you down for having a big dream
but for whatever reason, I was encouraged.
So I moved to LA
and I go to my film classes and I realized--
You go to Spielberg's film school.
And you made that happen.
Yes. But it was all rooted in this idea
that I thought I knew
that I was supposed to do that.
And then I actually started doing it.
And I realized not only is this horrible
that I will be horrible at this.
And I hate this.
And I had this major in college
this major identity crisis of
I promised everyone I would do this thing
and now I'm doing it or trying to do it.
And now I don't wanna do it.
And so what do I do?
And I mean, ultimately I just had to give up
because I just knew I'd be terrible.
But then I was this rudderless boat
at my whole developing brain
in adolescents had had this very bright North
star that was just now wiped blank.
And so then I spent college undeclared
not knowing finally declaring English.
Then I went to law school because I was like,
well now I have no skills,
except I can know how to read a book.
So I'm gonna go to law school.
So I have like some tangible skill.
And then, I discover my friends have
started this nonprofit and they need a lawyer.
And I'm so like, exhausted from working
in the like legal jobs that I had in law school.
I was like, I just need to be
around a community of people doing something inspiring.
So what it was I was just kind of walking through
any door that was opened that felt right at the moment.
And I did not have this big eye from 19 to 27
I would have said, I don't know why I'm on this planet.
I have no idea.
And then it was really the slow,
what loves you?
Or no, what do you love and what loves you back?
This idea that I started Invisible Children
writing a lot of the campaigns and then being encouraged
by them like, we liked the way you said that.
Will you come into this meeting and help us write this.
I'm like, okay.
And then that float into them,
like we need you to be our head writer.
And I'm like, really?
They're like, we like the way you articulate.
And so, and I loved that so much.
It was sort of this ebb
and flow of actually paying attention
to the winds in the sails of my life
of where the wind is moving and like use that to go forward.
And so it was almost like uncovering the writer inside me.
And then once I started doing that and it bore fruit,
it made me feel very accomplished
and it made me feel very worthy to be alive.
And so if I really extrapolate what that means,
it's not like I think everyone has
some specific dream career.
I think everybody wants to do something that feels useful.
And I found that for myself.
But it's in the doing that you have
that discovery and the tacking,
like making little adjustments
along the way that are based
on external feedback that you're getting from others.
Like, Hey, you're pretty good at this.
And realizing, I actually like that.
And let me just maneuver
you know what I'm doing a little bit in this direction
until one day, you're like, I guess I'm a writer.
It kind of happened to you
in the process of you just moving forward
with your life as opposed to declaring in middle school.
Like I'm gonna be hacks before,
you know what that means.
But not for nothing.
I actually think you'd be a very good filmmaker
good director.
Maybe not like a "Jurassic Park"
like I see you more as like a Mike Nichols.
Like you're somebody who I am certain would work very well
with actors in an emotional setting
and could make like a wonderful movie like that.
I mean, God knows, I love the idea.
But back on this idea of you know
like the pressure to find your passion
or to have this career, that's gonna, you know,
be sort of big in the scheme of how culture
perceives these things.
You talk about your friendship with Tom.
And I can only assume this is Tom Shadyac.
It is right.
Of course it is.
It's like, this is definitely Tom Shadyac
and he has this great line where he tells you
your generation has an idolatry of magnitude.
And it's probably one
of my favorite lines in the whole book.
So let's spend a few minutes talking about what that means.
Well, he, I remember he originally said
that talking about Invisible Children.
And he was because we were at Invisible Children
not only were we trying to arrest Joseph Kony
and end the longest running war in Central East Africa
but we also wanted to change the world.
We wanted to bolster international human rights.
We wanted war crimes against children to be something
that everyone on the planet cares about and rallies around.
It was such this like giant thing
and pinning it all on arresting Joseph Kony.
And seeing him tried before the ICC was such this, like
if we haven't done that we have failed.
And he would always say, he's such a mentor in our life.
He's like, you have put thousands of kids through schools.
You have built schools
you have awakened hundreds of thousands
if not millions of Western teenagers
to international human rights,
to caring about something outside their building
and their small world
you have gotten bills passed
through the Obama administration to help
with the pursuit of these war criminals.
You've done it.
You've done so much.
And you can't see it because you've decided
if you do not turn the world upside down
and change it then you have failed.
And that robs you of
both the stamina provided by incremental success.
And also just the reality
of understanding that it's not everyone's duty to
change the world changing someone's life,
right in front of you
or one child's life or five children's lives
whatever is so cosmically significant.
And if you overlook that, then you damage and disrespect
the impact you've already had or are having.
And I think a lot of people, whether it's I talk
with my agent and my editor about this a lot
because I get asked by people,
how do I get published?
How do I get noticed?
How do I get an agent?
And the question is that my agent calls it
the hidden desire behind the question.
It's like, what is the spirit of your question?
Because is it actually
how do I get validated for my writing?
And I need validation.
He says, it's also the hidden desire
in the question when someone says
how do you handle the critics?
And that the hidden nature of that question is how do I
I really care what people think
about my products so much so that I'm so afraid
of putting it out there because
what if someone doesn't like it
and I need validation for my work.
And so there's just this like,
idea that if I'm not published and on a bookshelf
if I'm not this or that,
if I haven't achieved A, B, C, D
or any than, I'm not a real blank.
And I think in the journey of figuring
out what you're good at and what love, what you love
and what loves you and what you're supposed to be doing
and how you can be useful and helpful in this life is
is if you feel a pull towards something
no matter how big or small, then like in some way, try it.
And that was my entire intention
with writing "To Shake the Sleeping Self"
was I don't know if I can write a book
I actually might be bad and I might embarrass myself
but I'm willing to try and put it out there.
And I'm so happy to self publish because I just
wanna hold it in my hands and know I did a thing.
And then I can move on with my life and find some other job.
Or if the wind doesn't tack in that direction
I'll tack the other way.
Great. I can do that.
But the writing was a compulsion.
It was something that had to be birthed.
You had to express it.
There was a call to the doing of it.
It wasn't about, can I get an agent or a book deal.
It was about basically the process
of giving voice to this thing that was inside of you.
Totally the writing in and of itself
is the thing I wanted to do,
because I had learned
that when I would write something originally
I had a blog on Blogspot,
which then became Tumblr
and it was called "The Water is Black"
which I love that title,
which came from a poem about being gay and God hating me.
And so I would write my thoughts
about my like sexuality and Christianity on this blog
just because when something would really
bother me this happens to me now.
Like something will really eat up my mind,
but I can feel the war of ideas in my head.
And then it's like, I just need to go sit down and write
about this and do some research and figure out what I think.
So it's the writing that gives you clarity
on what you actually believe about a specific thing?
Well, I don't know if you go for a number of days
without working out your,
my body starts to like ache hurt.
It's like, I don't know if that's atrophy or just stiffness
but it's like, if I don't exercise,
then my body bothers me.
And so then I go sweat and I get the endorphins
and I feel limber and great.
In the same way if I don't like, if I'm absorbing the world
and something's happening something complex,
like right now, I'm fascinated
by the concept of multiculturalism
and assimilation into a nation
right now with the the whole conversation around France
and what they're doing with so many Muslim immigrants
and how unlike America which is feigned
for being a melting pot
France is like a really old country
with like a very established multi thousand year old
traditional indigenous identity.
And so them processing that is so
short circuiting to my mind,
because I see both sides of the argument.
And I mean, it's obviously short-circuiting lots
of people's minds, but like, so for example,
I'm gonna eventually have to write this out
even if it's just for me,
because it's really it's something I can't get ahold of.
And it's like bothering me.
So originally I would do that with my sexuality
and my faith, and I would do it on this blog and one time
and I don't know why,
but I just felt really fired up
and I posted it on my Facebook,
just like I don't know why I felt ready to do that.
And I did.
And it, and it was that where people,
a lot of my friends read it and then they sent it
to their friends and their friends of friends
and strangers were messaging me saying this was so helpful.
And that was like some moments in my life.
Where that felt really where
I did something that was good for me.
And I discovered it was useful for someone else.
And that like really pulled me forward in loving that.
It's amazing how powerful a small seemingly small thing
like that can be in giving you the courage
the gumption to push forward
on something and kind of,
broaden the spectrum of what's possible for yourself.
Cause in the moment it's not a big deal
like a couple other people read your thing
and thought it was cool, but how meaningful that was.
And even now you look,
New York Times bestseller
but it's I'm sure for you,
it's the handwritten letters that you get
in the mail from some kid in the South who feels alone.
That's exactly how I feel.
I remember, I forget if I write about this in "Like Streams"
but I remember realizing
even before I had had a book out that I already had
the very thing I dreamed, like,
remember when you wanted what you currently have.
I had it, which was,
I get to write things that make me feel
like I understand my own mind that then strangers respond to
and say me too.
And they take time out of their day
to tell me what it means to them.
This was such a, that it lands on me so tenderly
and means so much to me because I'll never forget when.
And we talked about this on another podcast,
but when we made "Kony 2012" and it was like,
everyone was loving it.
And then there was the backlash everyone was hating.
There was a whole lot of weirdness.
And just getting like,
just getting so much hate mail
but then understanding that more people liked it
that didn't like it.
But the people that didn't like it were so loud
and so hurting our feelings.
And I remember thinking why
why aren't more people encouraging us.
And then at the time
my favorite thing in the world was
Ira Glass and Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich.
So like "Radiolab" and "This American Life."
Where my all I did all day was listened
to every episode and love them.
And it never crossed my mind to write them an email
and say, thank you.
I never would have done that.
And they're literally--
They love handwritten letter.
Yeah. Like I'm a super fan and they have no idea.
Not granted they can see that someone listened like one tick
on a number in some spreadsheet,
but like they have no idea.
And so now when someone writes me to tell me
and this happens all the time, I always respond with
thank you for being the type
of person that would take the time to tell me this
because you could have just not set that
how easy you could have just liked that
and be like, that was great.
I have like, never left a Yelp review.
I've never left, but I don't review anything.
When you were 10 you did write a letter to an animator.
Eric Goldberg.
That was one of those nudge moments,
those little moments in your life
that change your trajectory.
Miles Adcox who runs onsite the most incredible, like
I don't even know what to call it.
Like retreat center for like self expansion and learning.
He always says he uses the boat analogy
sort of like tacking where he's like,
if you're crossing the Atlantic ocean
and you turn the boat one degree early on,
or whenever like over the course of time
is the difference between South Africa and Ireland.
Like you just go and then it's.
And for me, I really do believe that was
such a moment where I'll tell the story really quick.
I was, this is okay.
The year before "Jurassic Park"
I was obsessed with "Aladdin."
This is great time to be a kid, these movies.
And I was obsessed with the genie and Robin Williams
and my mom, I mean, and I loved drawing.
So I would draw the genie all the time.
And my mom goes, you should write the animator a letter.
And of course I knew the animator, everything about them
because I would go back then and the malls
maybe they still have these
the Disney Store where it was like fully virtual
a vertically integrated consumer world
where you could just give all your money to Disney
which I'm sure you still can.
Now more than ever.
Now more than ever exactly.
"Star Wars" they actually take all my money.
They own more now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I would get these
behind the scenes books of how they made Disney movies.
And I would learn all about these animators
and how they draw.
And then I would watch these on the Disney channel.
I would watch them work.
So I just, I thought Eric Goldberg was God
because he could, he created the genie.
He drew this genie.
And this is 92,
so we didn't have the internet if we did
it was the most rudimentary,
but I don't think we got the internet until 94, 95.
And so somehow my mother said, draw him a picture
and I will find out where he is and we will sell
we will mail it to him.
And I was like, mother, you are so naive.
You know me at nine years old,
you can't just talk to these people.
They are in Burbank, California,
and whatever that was and--
This magical wonder land, Burbank.
So somehow she got on the phone and figured out,
I don't know what she did, but she got an address
and put it in an envelope and mailed it away.
And I just, it wasn't even like waiting
and checking the mail every day.
I just thought it was like burning it, like, okay, bye.
And then however much time passed.
I got the letter back and he drew me a picture
an original picture of the genie that said,
yo, Jed I ain't never had a friend like you
and wrote me this letter encouraging me to keep drawing
and like chasing my dreams.
And it just like whatever neural pathway that did
in my brain to be like,
there is no one you can't talk to.
And there's like, no one is beyond reach.
Like, it's fine.
Everyone's a person like the,
it just did something to my nine year old brain
that I still have with me now
where I'm completely unafraid and I've talking
to anybody and I feel very natural in any space.
But you know, of course like this guy is not a household.
This is not writing Steven Spielberg.
Like he was, it was probably very meaningful to him.
I'm sure that guy, you know
as talented as he is,
is toiling behind the scenes.
He's not getting handwritten letters from anybody.
So it was probably, you should have
you should look him up.
Is he still alive?
Try to find him.
No, I someone I think got me his email, I have to go back.
It was like in a very busy time,
but I posted about this story and someone goes,
you know he still works at Disney or so it's like,
and here's his email.
And I mean, even at 37 years old
I was like, Eric Goldberg, I can't email him.
I can't even
but I really do wanna send them a copy of the book.
You have to do that.
It changed my life.
And I love how your mom took it upon herself
to like figure it out, like what a beautiful thing.
And Barb is wonderful and complicated.
And can we talk about her a little bit?
I listened to the podcast that you did with her
which I thought was really interesting.
I think that I did a podcast with my dad.
I think everybody should do a podcast
with at least one of their parents.
There's something about the formality
and the structure of it that lends itself
to a kind of conversation that a child
and a parent just ordinarily are unlikely to have and
not to shoot, even share it with anybody
but just to like have it for posterity is a cool thing.
I think about my beloved Mimi
who I write about in this book,
my grandmother my mom's mom was such an incredible person
and I don't have really her voice recorded almost anywhere.
There's one, I have one video
on an old Vimeo account where we were playing cards.
And I had just like
had gotten a digital camera somehow and like uploaded it.
And just to hear her say three words
like rockets me to this
like nostalgic warmth and also melancholy of missing her.
And if I had like a full on interview with her,
I would just melt.
I would listen to it all the time.
But of course I don't.
And so I think that's such a great idea and so easy.
You can do it on your phone.
I recorded that entire podcast
with my mom on my phone.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
It sounded great.
We both, we got, we laid on her bed and I put pillows
in between us and I just set it right here.
And we like talked like this really close.
Well, what I got out of it,
and what I think is instructive
about it is that it was a beautiful example
of how to dance with somebody who sees the world differently
and do it with respect.
Like clearly there's, you guys have gone through a lot
and you have different worldviews
but there's a deep love there.
And how you try to find a way to establish
that common ground is almost like a test case
for this moment that we're in right now
where we're seeing this breakdown
in our ability to effectively communicate and we're become,
every issue is partisan.
And we're unable to kind of remember that we're all humans
spinning around on this planet in equal time.
And I didn't know what to expect when I was listening to it
having some sense of the background and,
and everything that you've kind of endured with her
and what happened when the first book came out
and her reaction to reading early drafts of that.
But I came away from that experience with
with an understanding that like
A, you've done a lot
of work to be able to bridge that gap and you know
kind of be there for her in a way that maybe
without that growth you wouldn't be able to.
And just her deep love for you.
Like that was the more surprising thing
because I'd never heard her perspective
on any of this before.
That was also when I decided to do that.
I wanted to give her the chance to really speak
because her ultimate critique with the book
even though she came to love it,
when she was reading the manuscript before anyone else had
she thought that I was mocking her or making fun of her
whereas my editor was so genius.
He goes, ask her to go in
to all of your conversations, where you
where she feels like you're misrepresenting her words
and have her write what she would really say
which was such a genius thing
because not only did it make it truer
it made it better because her perspective is real.
And it's like,
and like my the way it made me feel doesn't change
because her putting her true words
in there are just more accurate to the way it makes me feel.
But I just really wanted her to feel
like she had her say,
there's actually a lot of chatter.
My sort of the idea of memorializing,
a relationship by recording a podcast
with a parent or a grandparent
I haven't landed on this idea
but I eventually wanna do it in some form
whether it's my next book or not,
but to go on a road trip
across America with my mom and record the whole thing.
And we interact with people
of different faiths and political ideologies.
And we both process it together because
like you're saying I think we are
in this moment of like conversation crisis that,
I mean I'm very progressive lefty.
I mean, I'm central centrist left
but like I see the way the left dunks
on the right constantly and just dehumanizes them.
And like, basically, because they believe
that their ideas are dangerous and dehumanizing
that they just dehumanize them to a degree
that is hilarious because any psychologist,
any person who understands human behavior knows
the only thing you're doing is making them dig their heels
in more and making them love someone like Donald Trump.
That's the own you are creating this.
And I remember I saw this with my aunt.
My aunt lives in Rural, Missouri
and we've always like loved each other.
She's an artist.
She's like creative, gardening.
And then I started when the rise
of our last president started happening
and I started posting just like, this is not good.
I don't, this person is not good for America.
I don't think.
And she came at me with such rage
which we had only ever loved each other our whole life.
And to the point where I had to like block her on Facebook
because I was like, what has happened?
It was very strange
to me where I'd never had someone that I liked
out of nowhere just attack me
and call me a liberal elite
and a snowflake and a blinded this and whatever.
And I was like, what are these terms?
What is happening?
And it was this--
You're blind to it, Jed
because you live in Hollywood now.
Exactly. I am in a siloed media stream.
And so as she, and so are so many people
and it's like she was responding to a feeling
that the left was just making fun
of everyone else in America and the coasts or whatever.
And that is enraging.
And so you just double down and you like
I'm just like
we cannot survive this as a culture or a country.
I'm right now, reading Jill Lepore fantastic book,
"These Truths", and it's this incredibly
sweeping overview of American history.
And you realize that like
this is exactly what been doing the whole time is like
figuring out how opposing ideas like the Federalist papers.
They're all arguing the same things of like
big government, small government.
Does giving people money help them
or does it make them lazy?
Like everything we argue about we've been arguing about.
But now everybody has a megaphone
and we're in a culture where for whatever reason,
like it's become more difficult to hear
or listen to each other.
It's all about amplifying one's voice and being heard,
but without the hearing.
Well there's, and it's also the structures of
the way that these megaphones are built.
It's it actually doesn't help
for me to give some long nuanced perspective in a post.
Especially, in certain algorithmic social media platforms
like Twitter or Facebook,
where people that are not part of my community
are able to see that.
So if I tweet something
and somebody strangers can now see that and respond to it
whereas if I post something on Instagram
if you don't follow me, you're not gonna see it.
And so it's just a different energetic conversation
which is why I found myself writing on Instagram
and trying to have more nuanced conversations on there.
Cause I was like, I'm super down to be challenged
but there is a there's cachet in Twitter
or Facebook where I can write something really
complex and nuanced.
And then on Twitter, someone can pull one sentence
out of that and like then dunk on me and like
make some really hyperbolic statement about whatever.
And then they're because they are so black
and white and starkly bright
in their language that gets the attention.
And then like taints the entire conversation above it.
It's just a different energy.
That's why I don't
I don't really have conversations on the other platforms
because I don't like the way it feels.
So as somebody who who's,
I mean you spend your time either in Los Angeles
but you spend a lot of time in Tennessee,
so you have your foot relatively firmly planted into,
very different culture.
So you have a sense of this divide that is more boots
on the ground than the average person.
So as somebody who spends a lot of time thinking
and writing about their perspective on things,
like, what is the path forward here?
I mean, we can throw out perfunctory terms, like,
we need to lead with curiosity and we need to,
be patient and it's about nuance and all of that
but like practicing that or,
like how do you transcend the bubble and
live in the experience of others so that
we can heal some of these wounds?
Cause I do despair about the future.
Like where is this headed
if we don't course correct
in some real fundamental way?
I actually thought that something
like a pandemic would help.
I remember when this first I remember when this happened
I go, Oh my gosh, well, we're all gonna go
through something to get in the way and this like
cause I remember one of my heroes, Jonathan Haidt talk
he's built his whole life studying
like the left right divide.
And his theory was in less alien
from another solar system invade us
we are not gonna get along anytime soon.
And I was just like, Oh God.
And now I think if aliens came
we would turn it into some kind of weird partisan.
Oh totally, it would be like, they're not really here.
And then until you get zapped, then you're like
well that was actually paid actors.
It's like there's no hope.
But so to be honest, to answer your question
the only thing that made me remotely balanced
and understanding is personal relationships and immersion
with people that believe things different than me.
Like I went to my step-mom's neighborhood
in middle Tennessee
and there was a full-on Trump parade this past fall.
And it was the time of their lives.
These people were so kind, it was not
it was not racially homogenous.
There was like different, I mean it was mostly white people
but it was a very strange jovial non redneck moment.
And I was just, I was like, wow, these people are fired up.
And if you are in that, it's so interesting.
If you are in that world and at these parades
you do kind of think,
and you've you never go to Los Angeles or Berkeley
or what you really do
think everyone around you is voting for Trump.
How could he not win by a landslide?
Everyone you know voted for Trump.
So how could he not win?
And then when he says I won by a landslide
and they're trying to steal it from you,
you're like well maybe he's not lying.
And then Rudy Giuliani is up there sweating his face off,
saying there, we got all the proof.
It's a cause we're,
if you don't have access
to the other side and you don't engage with them personally
I don't know the way forward.
I truly the thing is I feel
to some degree I am an observational human, not a doctor
and so, and this has a lot to do
with the fact that I think because of
because of realizing I was gay and my adolescence
my defense mechanism for that was disassociation
is was floating above my own life
and just watching it curiously rather
than feeling hurt by being called words and whatever.
And so I think
that defense mechanism has influenced my entire life
and become my career as a writer and observer.
And I do feel like I observed humanity
in the sense where humanity
is a experiment of evolution that might not work.
Like we might not be able to do this
and that's in my mind fine.
This experiment may come to an end
or we'll just invent some AI to be the next evolution
of what we were meant to be.
Yeah. I just, I love humanity.
I'm so glad we're here.
I'm so I think it's very cool to be alive
but also I was not alive for a few billion years
before I was, and I didn't seem to mind.
If we go away and this is a failure,
it's just like I really hope we don't.
But there's this, when you mix things
when you throw things into the mix,
like humans are the human brain is pretty wired to like sway
conservative or progressive,
just the way that it is.
I mean, you look at almost every family
and within a same cluster of children who grew up
in the same house with the same parents
they can be politically divergent.
And oftentimes there's one or more that are
and you're like, they're eating the same food.
They're in the same place.
How does this happen?
And it's just because we've evolved to do that.
One is like scarcity
and one is curiosity and one is openness to experience.
And one is like preserving what the gains
that we've made in the past.
And these all have varying benefits.
I mean, you think about the American ethos of individualism
and Liberty is something that we are so proud of
but it made us incredibly bad at responding to a pandemic.
Whereas China, which squash has dissent
and potentially commits genocide
on ethnic minorities is completely homogenous
in their messaging and whatever.
And they lock that up.
And so if this pathogen was actually worse,
let's say it was more
like AIDS where it actually lays dormant
in you for six months or something
and then kills 30% of the population.
Or if it like AIDS was a hundred percent
every American would be dead
because if there was that incubation period
no one would believe it's real.
And like Dr. Fauci would be like, we can detect it.
We know it's real.
And they'd be like, there's nobody dead.
This is fake.
They're trying to control us.
And it's just like
and so you see how this experiment of humanity
you put moral judgments on the way people behave
which I think you should,
it's like the pursuit of thriving
but there are different ways of existing.
And in the experiment of
we don't know what the future holds
the fact that everyone does things a little differently
and cultures are expressions of like that.
Sometimes one culture works better
than another one and responding to a specific problem.
The individualism that is part and parcel of our DNA
as Americans is certainly aspirational this idea
that we can all kind of create our lives
in the vision that we would like in a perfect world,
but it's also it's shrouded in this patriotism.
But that patriotism doesn't mean anything
if we can't cohere as a nation
when we're faced with a crisis.
So we're seeing this fracture and I think,
to speak to the solution, as long as the,
the wealth gap continues to increase
it seems hopeless in my mind,
like the more the halves get
in and the less that the have-nots are have access to,
it's only gonna ratchet this whole thing up
and that doesn't bode well.
And that's the French revolution.
Yeah, exactly.
It will end in some kind
of similar catechism and maybe we need that.
I mean, that's the like brutality
of human history you look at, it's just blood bats.
I'm curious if there's certain aspects
to our political culture that are encouraging to me
obviously a capital insurrection is not encouraging
but a super divided government is interesting
to me in terms of like the evolution of society
because if 50, like our Senate is 50 50.
And that's like, if you are debating
over really complex problems that literally
one out of every two people can disagree on
then the problem is then you're probably living
in a pretty advanced society
if we can live in the same world
and two people in the same room can believe
opposite about something.
If the room was literally on fire and your skin is burning
you're not gonna argue over the fire department.
They're coming.
That's a very clear that is such a cause
and effect problem with no gray area.
But if you're talking about what makes the economy work
what rises people out of poverty?
Is it this or is it that?
What is actually gonna change
in climate the climate crisis,
if there is one or is this just the natural,
like those things are so complex
and they're very serious and may cause
the downfall of our society.
But in terms it's pretty remarkable that you can have
like the leaders of the country divided down the middle.
That just means that society is now so complex
that we solved a lot of the most obvious problems.
But that complexity leads to
a certain paralysis when
government is divided to that extent.
But then if his paralysis, if it okay,
if it is divided to that extent,
hopefully in a democracy
even though ours is a little screwy
it doesn't necessarily represent
that half the country believes this,
but a large amount of them believe one way
and a larger amount believe another
but if it was less divided
and yet there were that same division of beliefs
in the country and they just like forced the other half
of the country to be doing something they didn't wanna
do that would lead to, I think,
more insurrections and more--
Well, I think that's a function of the
caliber and quality of those beliefs
or those beliefs deeply held values
or are they surface level beliefs about,
things more trivial.
And when you get into a real differentiation
of value systems,
I think that's where it becomes very difficult to reproach.
Well, I mean, and that's the genius behind lobbyists
and marketing is if you make something like gay marriage
which the evangelicals in this country, it's like,
if I get gay married over here that doesn't affect
your straight marriage and your family,
but then they they sell it as
this like cancer that will erode all marriage.
And it will not only that,
but it will erode the sanctity of scripture,
which you've built your whole life on.
They give it the power to destroy everything else.
And so they make it a symbol,
this like seemingly small thing.
And so any that's what lobbyists do is
they try to make it where,
if you take away the soybean subsidy
you actually destroy A, B, C, D, and E in every direction.
Well on the gay marriage thing.
I mean, not, yeah.
Then culture shifts and people's perceptions.
I mean, that you know
it was interesting to hear Fran Lebowitz talk about that.
Cause she was like, that's never,
it's never gonna happen.
And she was as surprised as anybody that
that actually like took place.
I even think about, I mean
to bring it back to Britney Spears watching of course
well watching that documentary was really--
I watched it last night.
Was really interesting to me because 2007
2008 was not that long ago.
And it was just open season to make fun of these women
and to make fun of substance abuse and rehab
and mental health like dunking on them, slam dunking.
And what's even interesting now is that made me think
about "Kony 2012" and my best friend, Jason Russell
having a mental health crisis in public
and then having everyone make fun of him
and "South Park" make a whole episode about him.
And like, even now I feel like
10 years later that would be so unacceptable to
like mock somebody having a mental health crisis like that.
We even just have a different language around it
that feels to look at the way that people spoke about that.
And I remember it
because it happened to me and my community.
I felt the claustrophobic trauma of,
Wow. People do not understand the gravity
and realness of this and it's a joke to them
which is certainly what Britney felt being
like hunted and then mocked on national television.
Yeah. I mean, it's so sad watching that
and seeing what that young girl had to endure.
It's just, it's heartbreaking to watch it and to see
like the one thing I didn't realize
is like how deeply strange her Instagram is.
And it's clearly like somebody who's not as mentally fit
as they could be.
And I don't know whether they need a conservator.
I mean, that's a whole other subject,
but you know this woman has endured a lot
and it is interesting that it wasn't that long ago.
And when you see those interviews,
it's just they don't age well,
and now that's brought up a broader issue about this,
we're seeing like the Lindsay Lohan interviews
and kind of how she was treated by the public
and the whole those events coincided
with the explosion of the paparazzi media
and all of those tabloid magazines that were profiting
off of all of the schadenfreude.
And it's, you know, it's,
I'm glad that these documentaries exist now
and that there is a kind of cultural agreement that
that was not handled well.
And we should have a more meaningful conversation
about mental health and a recognition that these people
are human beings with feelings, just like everybody else.
I really hope so.
I feel like one of my favorite things about
any documentary is when it expands my understanding
and empathy for a situation
I just also watched the Tiger Woods documentary.
Yeah, I saw that too.
And it's a similar story.
And then it's like even it's so funny,
like Fran Lebowitz being surprised
about gay marriage and the "Me Too" movement.
I hadn't realized until I watched
the Tiger Woods documentary
I was sitting there with my roommate
and he goes, so he cheated on his wife, isn't that private?
Like, why do we care?
And I hadn't even thought of that.
I was like, you're right.
It feels really invasive and violating to
for like me to have an opinion about his marriage.
He's a golfer.
He's not a marriage therapist.
If my marriage therapist is cheating on their spouse,
well that's the whole point of why I'm paying them.
So that's relevant, but why?
And I was raised in the South and in Christianity.
And I remember as a kid
when Bill Clinton was being impeached
the progressive media being like, why do we care
what's going on in his marriage
and if he's being faithful to his wife?
And my family was like, well, that impugns everything.
If he's actually not honest in this way
then he's on not honest in another thing.
And so he must be impeached
which is hilarious that they voted for Donald Trump
but it's just the way things change where
I'm watching this Tiger documentary.
And I'm like, I don't think
that we should be involved in that at all.
And yet they're like selling these stories
and he's losing endorsement deals who cares.
Yeah. And the kind of disturbing glee with which that
National Enquirer write
the guy with the bow tie.
How like sort of excited he was
about being able to like uncover this.
It was like a big game hunting for him.
It's really, yeah, disturbing.
I understand like humanizing gods,
like trying to find them
I get that inclination, but it's just like--
But to draw a parallel between between Tiger and Britney
these are people who were foisted into the public eye
at a very early age and were,
subject to image crafting where a lot of interested parties
who had a lot to gain financially through their success
were heavily invested in kind of controlling their lives
and the narrative around their lives.
And part of that was this wholesome image.
With Britney, at least in the early part of her career
and Tiger just being this super clean cut guy
and something's got to crack
like humans aren't wired for that.
And at some point it's gonna go haywire
and it does like every time.
So whether it's shaving your head or escaping to Vegas,
people need an outlet.
How old are your kids?
The boys are 25 and 24 and the girls are 17 and 13.
Okay. What is it like raising a Gen Z?
Because my friends who have kids who are
like able to talk and like ten or older
you ask them what a kid wants to be now
and they say a YouTube star or a TikTok star.
I'm like, that's what they're like when it was my age
I wanted to be a Marine biologist or a Steven Spielberg.
But, so what is your,
and I don't know your kids at all but are they, like,
if they were like I want to be TikTok famous,
would you be, go for it here's a camera?
Or would you be like, not till you're this age?
What's your philosophy on that?
I mean, I would be very circumspect about that.
And you know my kids aren't necessarily
a proxy for the average kid.
I mean, my older boys are the most analog people
that I know.
Like they are rarely,
I mean, they're on Reddit and they read stuff online
but they don't have social media presences at all.
And they're artists and musicians
and they live in Echo Park,
they're home for the pandemic
but they're trying to pursue a music career
and are kind of immersed in that culture.
You see like a Luddite revolution amongst young people.
They're kind of the, I mean, you know
they wanted to record their album analog
and they listened to albums and
Like the ebb and flow
of you just respond to what was before you--
It's a desire for something that's tactile and real.
And they like read books
which is an act of revolution
when you're in your twenties, you know, in this age.
And then my 17 year old is in
she goes to a visual arts high school downtown
and she's all about painting.
And she's got like a screen printing business and,
so she's online, but it's mostly
like Snapchat with her friends.
She's not trying to build a persona online.
And then our youngest had a flirtation with TikTok
and there was a moment where she had like a lot
of people who were like watching her
and it freaked her out and she deleted her account.
It freaked her out, it did not freak you out.
She had the self-awareness to realize
that it wasn't good for her.
And I think there was some bullying involved in some,
kind of weird negative feedback
but she also had a lot of people who were kind of,
watching her do her thing.
And then she got rid of it on her own.
And now she's like writing a book
and writing poetry and doing other cool stuff.
So I don't know that that's the typical experience.
And I would agree with you that there is a whole generation
that aspires to be a quote on quote unquote
influencer or a YouTuber or a TikToker.
And that's what they're like, look,
my 13 year old doesn't even,
I would be surprised if she knew who Brad Pitt was,
but she knows who all these YouTubers are
and that's what's meaningful and important.
So that's a huge cultural shift.
So those are the people that they're looking to for,
everything from how to stuff like how do you make a cake
or all the kind of YouTube stuff where you can learn stuff
how do you take care of a snake to the vloggers and
the people that are doing beauty tutorials
and the like, like that is their culture.
I wonder if I'm realizing as you're speaking,
if we're gonna observe,
if you are a kid now,
you know that everything you do is documented online.
I know some of the kids that I know
and the younger people that I know it is very normal
for them to just delete old tweets and delete things
and delete everything after a little while.
Just so it doesn't just live online forever.
Where, when in me being Gen X, millennial cusp
like an elder millennial,
I have a lot of life
especially when we were using early social media
where it didn't cross your mind that like this embarrassing
inappropriate picture now lives forever
and 15 years can pass and it will resurface or whatever.
Like that's maybe like
that is just a curse of this specific moment of generation
but the younger people know that that's just what happens.
Well, I think the distinction is that we're the old
I mean, I'm older than you,
but when I went to college there was no internet, thank God.
And that started to percolate up,
I think, like you said, around 94 with email
and the like, but you know I am the last generation of
of knowing of being kind of adult enough
to know what it's like to not live with the internet.
And then being in this place now where it's all about that.
Whereas the, Gen Z has never known anything different.
So their relationship to privacy is extremely different.
They don't calibrate it in the same way.
And you know, there's a lot of dunking that goes
on on younger generations by older people.
But what I see is
such a greater receptivity and sensitivity
to issues of disenfranchisement and exposure,
global exposure to things that are going on in the world
and counter narratives to traditional notions of history
and politics that we just had our textbooks
and that was the definitive word on everything.
And there was no discussion that expanded outside
of that because unless you went to the library
and dusted off some weird book by some crazy professor
you weren't gonna get any other ideas.
I was 26 working at a Invisible Children's
surrounded by a bunch of activists.
And someone gave me
"A People's History of the United States" by Howard Zinn.
And I read the part about dropping atomic bombs on Japan.
I had never thought about the fact
that we dropped atomic bombs on civilians,
atomic bombs on families
as anything, but like,
World War II what a time
like I, America won World War II.
It never crossed my mind the like moral implications
of that action until I was 26 years old.
Because when I was told about World War II
no one gave you a counter narrative at all of like...
I did read that book in college though.
And I remember it blew my mind because
it runs so counter to just what you absorb in high school.
And you're just you don't
you're not really raised to question anything.
You're like, here's the thing,
read this and memorize it and we'll test you on it.
It wasn't it a discussion.
The flip side of that is without patriotism
without agreement showing the flip side
of every argument is very hard to create
any kind of cohesion in society.
Which is the very thing we were talking about
is hard for us to move forward.
When we all like are skeptical about everyone else's ideas,
and we just don't have much in common,
except we like siphoned ourselves into these other,
these communities of like-mindedness
where you think everyone must be like you
and everyone outside of your community is an alien
which we're just becoming tribal again
which is how we started.
Yeah. But I think,
that's one of the reasons why really
I love your reading and I like talking
to you because you do,
you have such a reverence for your roots
and the community that you came from
even though nobody would disparage you for saying,
showing it the hand and saying like
these are the people that bullied me
who didn't understand me,
and they're in my rear view
but you go back and you love them and you understand them.
And you're able to communicate a compassion
and an understanding of a culture
that's different from your own.
And I think that that's really powerful
as this observer who can on some level like disassociate
and look at things from 10,000 feet.
Well, I think every defense
and coping mechanism is an experiment in survival.
And so some people, when they feel unsafe, they run away.
When some people feel unsafe, they fight back.
For me, my for whatever reason,
defense and coping mechanism was to disassociate
and engage like and figure out,
you're a human you're in the hallways in seventh grade.
And people are picking on you making fun of your voice,
making fun of your clothes.
Like you can like rage against the machine
or you can figure out why the machine works
the way that it does and survive.
And that was just the way that sounded best for me.
And then that percolated.
And then I saw the fruit that it bears
which is the older I got.
And then I had all these friends who are
conservative Christian jocks,
and this and that graze in Tennessee.
Then they find out I'm gay.
And then by through relationship with me
it transforms their understanding of what a gay person is
because it's not what they were told at church or saw on TV.
So through that personal relationship and friendship,
it like for the rest of their life
they had a different perspective,
which they wouldn't have had necessarily without me.
And so I think that influenced the way that I see
any meaningful change is through
screaming at someone that you're wrong and shaming them.
I mean, you just see it, it turns people sour
and it turns people defensive.
And I don't know,
I would be very curious to see a study on this of like
how often shaming really works.
I will say one thing that it sort of worked is growing up
with no smoking commercials.
Like if you smoke, you will die.
I mean, I was like, Oh my God.
I think that there is a place for shame
in some regard, I think it can be like,
we're in a shameless society right now.
Shame's out the window.
And there is something to be said
for that kind of like, it's not okay to do.
We have, you know, we have people
in leadership positions who are utterly shameless
and people who are living their lives performatively
in a shameless way,
because that satisfies the algorithms and,
becomes a way to enrich oneself.
Yeah. I mean, what we have right now
is just access to see the complexity of everything.
So sure, we have very shameless politicians
and shameless people in power, but then you have,
if you have a minor player that posts
and a dumb tweet and gets fired from their job
and is like different than wiped out and is like,
they said something that is like insensitive or stupid
or they did something 15 years ago, 20 years ago
30 years ago that.
And so that, and then they're piled on.
The weaponization of shame to eradicate people.
And I think the weaponization
of shame to eradicate people
is part of what gave us such hyper shameful politicians
because they're actually people tired of that
social immune response respond and do the opposite
which is elevate somebody who just says F you to everybody.
They're like, yeah, finally someone's saying it.
And like, if enough of us are like, yeah, let him say it.
Then maybe they'll shut up
and we'll show them who has power.
Maybe we should all go back
and read "The Scarlet Letter" again?
There's just, it's so funny to me when you read
classic literature or you read American history
you realize how everything feels so new,
but it's just "Everything is a Remix"
which is a great YouTube series.
Back to Barb for a second,
when listening to the podcast with her,
and talking about the how do you reconcile
your love with somebody who's living their life
in a way that's difficult to understand what was
what I keyed in on with her is how she's put her faith
in this position of intermediary.
It's like, she clearly struggles with you being gay
because it's at odds with her faith,
but rather than castigate you or have judgment on that,
she puts God in between you and just says,
well I believe that God has a plan
for Jed and that gives her comfort.
Which I thought was really interesting.
I mean, you perfectly understand the situation,
which is she loves me and knows that like
God is more powerful than her.
And that her job is to love me
and not push me away and not push me away from God
because she also feels like a representative of God's love.
And so it's just such an interesting relationship
because also her biggest fear kind of happened
which wasn't just that I'm gay.
It's that the fear that she was sold,
which is if you pick and choose what you want from the Bible
then that negates the whole thing.
Like, if you can just decide
that you're not gonna follow God's words here,
you do the other thing.
And what's funny is I was sold that
which kept me celibate and in the church for so long.
But then once I started unraveling
that sweater and I was like, well, why is this word?
Why did Paul write this?
And why is this in Leviticus and Deuteronomy?
And like what, who wrote the Bible?
And then I'm like, why is this interrelated here?
And translate it here.
And what's the Council of Nicaea and how did
how come these people are deciding what goes in
and what about the Apocrypha and the Gnostic Gospels
all of a sudden, I'm so deep.
I'm like, well, if I had just been allowed to be gay
I would have never known any of this.
And I would have just loved Jesus all my life
and never asked all these questions.
But because this deep inner woven piece
of my identity caused me to become
hyper obsessed with knowing what's true.
It unraveled the whole show.
And now I can never go back.
I don't know.
Never. I mean, God has a plan.
Right, right.
I love how you, you characterize identity.
I think this is a quote from the book
the braided marriage of circumstance, ego and soul.
I mean, that is, we are where we came from.
We are what we think we are
and then how we feel about what we think we are.
And those like those,
the tension between those things is this dance of,
I mean identity is almost like the Bible,
which is, if you look at the concept of your soul or the I,
the ego, the who you are, you look at it too closely
and it starts to disappear and unravel,
like what made me want a breakfast burrito this morning?
I don't know.
But that was me that wants it, but who wants it?
Like what does that even mean?
So you can't look too close.
I wanted to find this.
Here it is.
I thought that was so interesting because these words
what do they even mean anymore?
Be authentic like find your own community.
And they've been so commodified
and overused that they've been drained of
of any kind of weight that they carried at once.
And I love this passage.
So I'm gonna just read it.
The words authentic and community
don't mean anything on their own.
Some things are meant to be byproducts, not causes or aims.
We are desperate for authenticity and community.
And in our haste, we mistake them for goals.
But these things are like friendship
like flirting, like humor.
If you talk about them
they retreat like a shadow in the light.
You can not discuss pheromones while flirting
and expect your knees to keep touching under the table.
Some things, some beautiful things are the smoke
and not the fire.
In the same way you cannot will community into existence.
If you gather people around you and squint
and smile and say, we're such a community
how amazing are we?
Watch your friends run.
(chuckles)
I believe--
It's so good, right?
I mean, there was a season for a minute.
I was like gonna all these conferences and those things.
And that was just such the buzz
of like building everything was building a community.
Every company was building a community.
And I was just like, what are you talking about?
What is this?
And then I realized the best community I ever had
was at Invisible Children,
but we didn't try to build a community.
We tried to end a war.
Like we had a very sharp idea of what to do
and how to do it,
which was through creative storytelling
and inspiring the young people of the world.
And that pointed in that pointed desire
and intention attracted types of people and
like a diverse body of types of people into that mission.
And then as we were all facing in the same direction,
working towards something
you look to your left and your right.
And you're like, wow, this is dope.
Like, this feels really good to lean on each other
to use our skills and pursuit of the same common goal.
That's community.
But if you just all stand next
to each other and talk to, it's like, that's fine.
It's great but it's not gonna make you feel
that thing that I felt at Invisible Children.
The idea that that community
is a function of an activity or a purpose.
You talk about your trip down the Colorado River
and how that bred community
because it was an adventure.
It was a collective that came closer together
as a group of people because you are all doing one thing.
This you were, it was mission-based.
I mean, there's one of the reasons I love Fran Lebowitz
so much is because she talks about how lazy she is.
And one of the jobs of a writer is just to hang out.
She's like, it's part
of my job to just like smoke a cigarette
and hang out and talk about nothing and not do anything.
Cause I it's the aggregate experience
of collecting things to process.
And so I do think about like a lot of my best friends
that I would call my community are actually
we're just all doing different things.
And then in that friendship,
we don't have a common purpose.
We just like hanging out
and like brighten each other's days.
And that's fine.
But I would also say that's not
that is not nearly the same thing as like a cohesive
powerful community that changes your life.
One is like a restful resource and like a respite
and I'm using, and one is just this energetic organism.
And that is just a powerful feeling.
I do think that
that those conferences have their place though.
Like I've met, like I met Tom Shadyac
and like I just I'm so delighted that
like I got to have an experience with him
and the other person that I met as a result of,
doing a lot of these kind of events that don't exist anymore
because of the pandemic is
is I got to spend time with your friend Ruthie.
Who's a big part of this book.
Truly. I think he sends in there like 25 times.
And you say like spending time
with Ruthie is like a poem or a sermon, right?
Well, so she, this is sort of what you were saying
about experiencing reading a book or watching a good movie
or whatever you experienced someone else's truth
and life that is not your own.
And that is interesting.
And edifying and valuable.
We have enough in common.
We think we like the same music.
We like road trips, we laugh
but she has such a different life than me.
She is a six foot tall drink of water woman
with nerve damage in her spine
that causes her to have incredibly
debilitating chronic pain for her whole life.
And to the point where she lived
in her bed for seven years on the maximum legal dose
of fentanyl every single day,
and that didn't even help.
And so she weaned herself off and now just lives with it.
And there is an access to truths that she has
that I do not have.
And through our friendship, I learned so much
about so much and through,
and she says that she learns through me
through whatever my life experiences are.
And it just feels like this very healthy, educational
delightful dance that we have.
Yeah. There's a, there's a weird alchemy
between the two of you.
I mean, I think the greatest friendships in our lives,
at least to me have that
it's that magical alchemy where the
whatever chemical they are
and whatever chemical you are when you pour those two things
in the beaker, like light and smoke happens.
And it's just, that's a special combo.
Whereas I have other Alchemy's
with other friends where it's a different experience
but equally as powerful to me.
You know I think we all have that.
Yeah. And you talk about how you're
at a point in your life now where it's not
about like making new friends,
but it's about really honoring the friendships that you have
and like tending to that to that garden
and growing old together and
and having your lives like be integrated
to such an extent that you get the
the richness of life as a result of those experiences.
We gotta wrap this up in a few minutes.
I have so many notes that I didn't get to
but one thing I do
I do wanna talk to you about the way we talk is.
Like where did we even go today?
I dunno. But one thing I love is this idea.
You talk about this in the death part, like
and I've heard you talk about this.
Like how we you know,
we scrub and whitewash death out of our experience.
We all live in this kind of collective denial that somehow
we're gonna sidestep this inevitability
and how we just bury people in these boxes.
And I've often thought,
like I don't wanna be buried in a box.
Like I wanna be buried in naturally in an organic garden.
And I want like amazing plants to grow out of this.
And I want all the people that I love
to sit down and have an unbelievable meal
and literally take my body into their bodies.
Why can't we do this?
There is a way to have like a natural burial.
I heard you talk about this.
I didn't know
that this was a thing that you could legally do.
Well, it's becoming, I think it's a movement.
So there's like a friend of mine named John Christian
helps run this thing called Larkspur.
This is a farm outside of Nashville that this woman,
I think bequeathed to this organization
that does natural burial.
And you go, and you
I think you can like pick out where you wanna be buried.
And it's basically just a gorgeous farm
with hiking trails and wild flowers
and a Creek and a barn and trails through it.
And then they just take your body and put you in the dirt.
And then you just decompose.
And it's like, amazing.
And to me, I'm like, that's exactly what I want.
And I think a lot of environmentally conscious people
which hopefully that number is growing every day
they realized, okay, obviously a normal graveyard
and a box and all that is very wasteful.
Cremation is actually a huge carbon footprint.
It takes a lot of energy
to turn someone into an ashtray like a lot.
And so that's not actually very helpful either
but just putting your body in the dirt
and feeding the soil and letting your nutrients disseminate
into the ground is beautiful and fantastic.
And I wanna feed a tree
and an earthworm and the grass, I think that's so cool.
And so like, let me do that.
And so this place called Larkspur is amazing.
And I think I'm very hopeful that it becomes the norm.
And I think it will even like baby boomers
both of my parents are like not interested...
In the typical traditional.
I wanna be cremated.
Yeah. Wow.
Well, let's close this down.
I mean, where do you, what do you like,
what is your when you think about
"Like Streams to the Ocean"
I suspect that as a writer, you want it
you want the reader to have their own experience
and you don't wanna taint or color that in any way.
But if there is kind of an aspiration
for what you want the reader to extract
or get out of the experience of reading this book
can you put words to that?
Absolutely. So bring to bring it back to my girlfriend.
Fran Lebowitz said in an interview this past summer
she was talking about how she's an excellent reader.
And she reads more books
than anybody and has more books than anybody.
And she said--
That's why she can't move out of her apartment.
Exactly. It's too many.
She said that she doesn't read for plot or story.
She doesn't care.
And which made me laugh, how a laughing.
She goes, I read for language.
I read sentence by sentence.
And I love the flow of language.
And I like the way that it lands on my mind.
I don't actually care if Sally slept with Jessica
and then, there's a note under the [Indistinct].
Who cares what happens?
I wanna know how this language flows into my mind,
which to me is also how I read.
Like the most extravagant plot
I almost don't notice it it's that if within this paragraph
did you make me feel some type of way?
Or did I learn something with each bite?
You know, it's almost like I wanna, I wanna read
and I wanna write the way that I eat,
which is I wanna enjoy the whole process of eating,
not just being nutritious and having a full stomach.
I want everything that I experienced with my mouth
each bite tastes good.
And so what I hoped for this book was to convey
what I love about reading,
which is I'm going to pour my brain
onto paper with the things that when I was working
out ideas that were confusing to me,
once I got them in these words,
I felt like I got to exhale.
And I felt that sense of revelation and joy that comes
with understanding something a little better.
And that's my favorite thing to do when I read.
And so my hope is the way that I felt writing this book
and the way that I feel when I read books that I love
is what someone reading it would feel.
Wow. Beautifully put.
Well, that was my experience reading it.
So, yeah, I've got like so much love
for you as a person, as an artist,
as a creative individual, you're a gift to the world.
This book is really it's special, man.
So thank you for writing it.
And I can't wait to see what you write next.
Are you well into the next thing?
No, I'm now I can't really work on a book
until I get over the hump of a book's released
because I need to like talk about it and think about it.
I can't be on to the next
but now I'm really processing what that's gonna be.
And I really think it might involve a lot of Barb.
Yeah. Good, good, good, good.
Well, it's gotta be challenging to try to release
a book in the pandemic when you can,
and as this is always hilarious to me,
like your couch has a travel writer.
Like I don't see you as a travel writer.
I don't know why that's in your bio.
Well, because my first book was a travel thing
and I'd written for some magazines, but I'm,
early on in my career,
it was trying to figure out what am I?
And so it's like, sometimes you kind of have to either call
call it forward or look back at a body of work and say,
that's what you are like, are you an SAS?
Are you a memoirist?
Who knows?
I just write things down.
I think you've transcended travel writer though.
Cool. And also I wanted to point out that
Ruthie book came out
it was the beginning of the pandemic, poor woman.
At the beginning when nobody knew what was going on--
She's such an engaged person.
Who wrote this amazing book.
And I just, I didn't know, like I wanted to have her
on the podcast, but I wanted to do in person
but it wasn't safe.
And then like that moment pass,
but like I really wanna have Ruthie come on
and share her story I think she's really powerful.
She would love that it would be great.
And her book is fantastic and profound.
Cool. So "Like Streams to the Ocean"
you can find it at find booksellers everywhere.
I suspect Jed would like you to purchase it
at an independent book seller if possible.
Definitely check them out at on Instagram
at Jedidiah Jenkins and fall in love with his writing
like I have and come back and talk to me whenever you want.
It is my favorite thing.
I could literally, if this podcast was like nine hours long
I would just need like a cup of tea
and we just go all nighters.
I have no doubt
that you would never run out of things to talk about.
All right, love you.
You're the best. Love you too.
Peace.